uh people in the audience have been
sending me more and more of these video
clips of Michael Shore our great friend
Michael Shore uh speaking to Trump
supporters at recent rallies as well as
other reporters and I want to play a few
of them and talk a little bit about it
we did a story a few months ago
about a group of
um uneducated white women who voted for
Trump in 2016 and being interviewed on
CNN and it was really bad and I said at
the time this may not be politically
correct this may not be polite but we
have to come to terms with the reality
that many voters have no clue it's
unfortunate it's not nice to say in
these terms maybe but the point is that
they have just as much of a right to
vote as anybody else and many of them do
vote we have to understand that we now
have some interviews done over the last
five or so days with various Trump
supporters at different events and it's
really bad it's just as bad before we
get to the Michael Shore Clips let's
start with one from CNN CNN asking Trump
rally goers over the last few days
why aren't you wearing a mask and it
instantly turns into wildly debunked
conspiracy theories
[Music]
but why not wear one just stay safe
I have a hard time understanding people
when they talk so that's why I don't
work but you can hear me right now I can
hear you sir
because there's no covet it's a it's a
fake pandemic created to destroy the
United States of America but the
president said to Bob Woodward that
there is a virus the coronavirus and
that it is devil that's his opinion the
truth is is that the CDC said there's
only less than 10 000 people die from
covid the other 190 000 have two 2.6 or
2.8 other immortalities kovid was
created to destroy the U.S that other
conspiracy theory by the way about you
know the real number of deaths is nine
thousand we've already debunked that
it's been widely debunked but the the
mess the important thing to glean is
even though it was debunked weeks ago
you still have these rally goers who
probably do vote I mean I think that if
you go to a rally you're almost
certainly voting they still are
repeating these uh conspiracy theories
uh and then it continues now taking sort
of a more religious approach about not
wearing a mask
crowded space I'm Not Afraid
the good Lord takes care of me if I die
I die we got to get this country moving
can't we can do wear masks and stay
inside for another year huh where will
that get it so that's really bad then we
have these Great Clips from our friend
Michael sure uh doing these interviews
for tyt and uh first folks going right
into socialism he says he's not a
socialist but all of his ideas that
sound like socialist ideas and everybody
around him are like socialists and they
all support that and he I think that as
soon as he's in office he will start
pushing socialism if he was in office
they're the devil
they got a lot of Satan in them
they're out for their own good they have
no interest in the United States of
America
and the day there who's the they the
Democrats
[Music]
Biden Pelosi
all of them uh they just got a lot of
evil in them they're not in the best
interest of the United States of America
I support Trump because he's not a
socialist
I'm a foreigner in America I lived in
two socialist countries and I want
nothing to do with socialism do you see
Joe Biden as a socialist
all right
the people that are handling him are
socialists yes there are no socialist
ideas from Joe Biden now what's what you
know I've said before I get criticized
for being a socialist even though I'm
not and for not being a socialist by
people who want me to be a socialist
many on the left wish Joe Biden were a
socialist he's not there's nothing
socialistic about Joe Biden's policies
here are supporters confronted by
Michael Shore with Donald Trump's
comments about soldiers who died in
combat being losers and suckers we
suspected that many of them would simply
say Trump didn't really say it and
that's exactly what many of them said
ridiculous the media all the lies they
put out there are ridiculous no
president's going to make a comment like
that definitely Donald Trump our
president is not going to make a comment
like that look what he's done with the
veterans he's done more for their
medical care than any other president
probably in the history of the country
so absolutely false and the media's
going to come out with something false
every day they continue to lie and lie
and lie and people are a lot of people
are aware of that if John Kelly did say
that happened what would you think of
that
I would disregard it because I know
there's over 25 people that said it
didn't occur doesn't fit with your world
view doesn't match your pre-existing
beliefs well then just say it didn't
happen here's another one that's all a
lie he loves a veterans
and I I I'd rather have him 10 times in
a head but but won't do nothing but sell
our country with China and anybody else
he can get a dollar from that's all he's
ever done since he's been in office uh
as as a military veteran some of the
stuff that's come out about what the
president's allegedly said about uh you
know Americans and cemeteries and and
whatnot and what he said about John
McCain a naval man has that given you
pause at all
it has not um he has he has to some
things that you know I see things off of
the spirit moment that I go back to
why did I say that for you know that
last guy interestingly
taking the approach not of denying that
Trump said it but denying that he meant
it and then this last one is really
special Michael Michael Shore from tyt
really doing a great job on these
um Trump supporters asked what will you
do if Donald Trump loses will you accept
the result of Joe Biden with no
under any circumstance no
why is that
because it's
lies and deceit and Corruption so this
is one strategy and again this is the
importance of paying attention to the
stories Trump tells they're ridiculous
stories but they work they stick to
people if Biden wins it would be fake
preemptively saying it'll be fake if
Biden wins take a look at this next one
I'll be knees praying a lot harder
praying for Joe Biden's success or
praying for four years from now
replacing Joe Biden
for God to help us
President Biden that can't happen I
can't even think about that because he
does not like America he's a racist now
that's a racist if you want to look at
someone who despises the black man the
black woman he looks out for himself
he's a crook his son is a crook he's a
criminal what happens if Donald Trump
loses do you have a fear of for the
country of Donald Trump you're nodding
your head okay you can evolve I'll ask
both of you we actually have plans to
move to Panama because it's a city or
it's a country that allows Americans to
move there and to actually own firearms
there I mean if they trust us enough to
own firearms as you know people with
legal right to be in their country
um you know it seems like a place that's
not planning to do something terrible to
their people but if he wins it means the
Democratic machine has won in some of
the illegal tactics that you know the
voter fraud
I I think that if he loses they come
after all of us supporters yeah Biden is
actually the racist now I know the
reaction from many of us when we watch
this stuff when we hear these clips is
discussed how are these our fellow
Americans how is it possible to have
such uneducated ignorant people in the
United States
this is the result of our education
system this is the result of religious
indoctrination this is the result of
Decades of anti-intellectualism going
back to I mean you know in a sense
anti-intellectualism has been around for
hundreds of years but certainly
prominently in the Republican party to
Reagan
and you know this imaginary Welfare
Queen with 12 kids and a Cadillac and
whatever the story was everything we've
been talking about this is the outcome
that we are seeing we are seeing it
front and center and it is very ugly uh
check out one other one here I've
actually considered leaving the country
moving to South America or something
like that if something like that happens
I've had neighbors that moved when
Hillary was running against President
Trump because he was convinced Hillary
was going to win he sold everything and
moved to Panama so
I'm thinking you know my ancestors did
that back in the 1900s when they left
Germany so I would hurt for my
grandchildren why South America I wonder
most of those governments in South
America are left-wing governments by
most standards now if the guy likes
authoritarians I guess he could look at
moving to Venezuela but I don't think
that's the idea of a better place for
most Trump voters but really really
stunning stuff and we have to resist you
know there's this thing that will often
happen on the left
where we start kind of moralizing and
talking about you know these poor stupid
people and blah blah blah blah blah they
vote and I think that we really need to
see them it's much more productive to
see these folks as victims rather than
perpetrators they are victims of an
education system that has failed they
are victims of in some cases religious
indoctrination they are victims of a
lack of media literacy and a corporate
media that thrives on salaciousness and
so on and so forth it's far more
productive to do that than to look down
at them from some moral High Ground
which I think is both unjustified in
many ways and completely
counterproductive let me know your
interpretation if you disagree with mine
and we'll have more of these clips on
the show Instagram page at davidpackman
show on Instagram
real quick I want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon who have done
something awesome they've taken all of
our favorite sugary childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry they taste great
they're crunchy they're sweet like you
would expect this type of cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free gluten-free grain free soy
free once our team tried magic spoon for
the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us more boxes send more samples
they've been a big hit with David
packman show staffers and Magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked and you'll get free shipping when
you go to magicspoon.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n